♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce sont de petites gravures,
à la fois modestes
et grandioses,
qui témoignentimimimimmensité
d'un territoire et du mode
de vie de ses habitants.
LYNE BASTIEN, artiste et
professeure d'arts platiques
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ici
aujourd'hui, ça m'émeut d'en
parler. Je ne m'attendais jamais
à ce que ça se rende ici.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Entre 2014 et 2019,
l'artiste Lyne Bastien est allée
à la rencontre d'Inuits,
pour la plupart des sculpteurs
de pierre et leur a transmis
sa passion pour la gravure.- - t
de la présence des Blancs dans
les communautés depuis quelques
siècles. J'étais très au courant
des effets de la colonisation.
Je ne voulais pas arriver dans
une communauté et tout prendre
et ne rien laisser.
Elle a mis sur pied des ateliers
itinérants et entrepris
de former des artistes
formateurse e e e e dizaine
de villages.
À Puvirnituq, elle a rencontré
la sculptrice de glace,
Maggie Napartuk.
- Le travail de Maggie, c'est un
travail d'une grande finesse.
C'est très, très beau.
Ça représente bien le Nunavik.
C'est une fille qui s'intéresse
beaucoup à la tradition, donc
elle avait beaucoup de choses
ninininininiquer.
- C'était plus simple d'arriver
avec deux formats.
- Les 60 estampes retenues
pour l'exposition présentent des
scènes de la vie quotidienne
du Grand Nord, mais aussi
des personnages de légendes,
réalisées par des hommes et des
femmes, jeunes et moins jeunes.
- Ici, le titre de l'oeuvre,
c'est : "Femme se transformant
en loup", alors dans
les histoires inuites,
il y a souvent des personnages
qui se transforment en animal.
♪ ♪ ♪
On voit des éléments
traditionnels dont l'igloo,
le harpon, mais c'est dans
un iPhone. C'est très actuel.
Et puis pour moi, ça crée,
encore là, un pont avec
les traditions et
des préoccupations
qui sont plus actuelles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La sélection des oeuvres
a posé des défis particuliers.
Lyne Bastien s'est entourée
de deux femmes artistes inuites,
dont Maggie Napartuk,
pour faire ces choix.
Pour les femmes, c'était
l'histoire. Les histoires
étaient importantes. C'était pas
juste de faire une belle image,
c'était de communiquer quelque
chose qui était important
au sujet de la culture.
- La gravure a mené
Maggie Napartuk vers le dessin.
Elle travaille actuellement
à la production d'un livre à
colorier qui illustre aussi
sa culture et son environnement,
tout comme l'ensemble
des oeuvres exposées.
- Je suis aussi très fière
de montrer au public ce qui sort
du Nunavik, qui est autre que
- Je suis aussi très fière
de montrer au public ce qui sort
du Nunavik, qui est autre que
ce qu'on peut publier dans
les journaux, à la télé,
sur les drames qu'il y a,
au Nunavik. Et oui, il y en a
des drames, mais il y a aussi
des choses magnifiques
qui se passe là-bas
et toutes les images qui sont
ici en témoignent bien.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'exposition "Résurgence,
l'estampe au Nunavik,
2014-2019" est présentée
au Musée d'art de Joliette
jusqu'au 9 janvier prochain.